hey what's up welcome to date one of
css3 in 30 days my name is Brad Hussey
and I'm gonna be helping you out over
the next 30 days or so to learn css3 by
actually building a bunch of things so
day one is the very beginning and we're
gonna be getting started with some
pretty cool stuff so let me show you
what we're gonna be doing right here in
the browser
so right here over in the browser this
is day 1 css3 fancy buttons I'm calling
it we're gonna be making some buttons
exclusively with css3 just to kind of
whet your whistle and get you excited
about what's to come this is a pretty
cool thing something you can use
immediately in your websites and all
that sort of stuff here's the shell kind
of the outline this is what every
lessons gonna look like we're not going
to be coding that up but you're welcome
to check out the CSS and the theme files
and stuff that's cool but what we're
gonna be building is going to be further
down here in the the web page so you can
see we've got the sandbox this is what
you're gonna be using too you're gonna
manipulate this to make it look like the
final result now below here is the final
result we'll scroll down we got the
final result and this is what we're
gonna be making this is the final
example of what we're gonna be doing we
got the Facebook style buttons we've got
a 3d buttons you know with some 3d cool
effects and the circle and all that sort
of stuff
we got the gradient bordered buttons
with some cool hover effects you can see
that here the border of these buttons
have gradients
that's a css3 kind of hacking they're
animated button so when you hover over
the buttons you get some cool animation
effects and then adding an element in
there we've got toggle switches changes
the text in the button and the color and
all that sort of thing the position of
the inside switch and then you know you
click to activate a button those sorts
of things so that is what we're gonna be
building in our lesson today for day one
css3 fancy buttons so what you need to
do before you get started is download
the course file so you can follow along
and actually start making something
right away I'll just click the link to
download the course files and you'll be
given a file that our folder a zip file
with a folder in it that's called one -
fancy buttons it's gonna have an index
file like so it's going to have a
sandbox that's CSS file which you're
going to be using to add your own CSS
and a final dot CSS file which has
everything that you need to reference if
you go through the code you mess
something up or you're not quite sure
about something that right there is
going to help you out you can use that
for reference while you're building your
projects and that final CSS is what
Styles over here in the browser this
stuff over here so the sandbox tiles
this this section the final result is
right here so those are the three files
that you're going to get in this the the
course files for this lesson and what
you need to do is just open up your
index file in your browser I'm using
atom as my code editor so I got my
course files in that code editor right
here but then it also has a feature
where you can open up the index.html
file in the preview over here so that's
what I'm doing but you can open it up in
a browser like Safari or Chrome and so I
suggest you go ahead and do that and
then open up your code editor open up
your sandbox dot CSS now that we're here
we should be at the same spot what we're
gonna start doing now is styling up
these Facebook style buttons let's just
jump in not waste any more time so in
the index file you're gonna see the CSS
classes that I use for the Facebook
style buttons Facebook style button and
then Facebook style dark and light so
let's just jump right in we're gonna say
Facebook style BTN and then we're gonna
say border-radius two pixels let's do
font size 0.9 ram that's referencing the
the root font size rather than the
parent font size that's a cool css3
feature padding we're gonna go six
pixels on the top and bottom 12 pixels
on the left and the right save that pop
over into your browser you can see
already the changes are taking place
looks pretty good so far nothing fancy
but you know we're getting there let's I
select the Facebook style a dark button
Facebook style dark and we're gonna
start adding some box shadows so just to
be up to date here we're gonna use Moz a
box shadow and then I'm gonna go ahead
and say inset and I'll explain this in a
minute 0 1 pixels 0
and then a color for d7 three the F I'm
gonna copy that whoa that needs to be a
pound sign not a dollar sign paste that
a couple times the second one going to
change to WebKit and this last one is
just box shadow and then I'm gonna tab
the the rule here whoops the style so
that we can have them line up properly
beautiful all right
so Maz is from Mozilla browsers WebKit
is for webkit-based browsers and box
shadow is just the fallback that you
know modern browsers are able to pull
from so that's what you would do to get
your box shadow you couldn't just put
box shadow but then you know some
browsers might not recognize it and then
you won't have the box shadow effect so
it's up to you if you want to do that
css3 is a bit progressive so some
browsers aren't quite up to date with
certain rules and styles and things like
that but at the bottom of every lesson
over here in the browser you can see how
compatible are these styles of major
browsers if you click on this link it'll
take you to a web site that will
basically say can I use you know box
shadow and you can see css3 box shadow
and where it works it works in these
versions of ie Firefox Chrome Safari and
you know you can kind of see so
basically it says unprefixed so this is
prefixed styles over here in the code
editor these are prefixed styles so
technically we don't even really need to
do that because it looks like 94.8% of
browsers are going to support the
unprefixed box shadow
so that's pretty cool let's see Safari
six iOS default browser iOS 6 don't work
with the zero pixel value or blur so
there's information there you know you
can reference that it's up to you if you
want to do that so I won't waste any
more of your time looking at that you
can do that on your own time so let's go
back to the style here there we go and
let's jump back in here and I'm gonna
explain this here inset it makes the box
shadow on the inside of the the box the
block level elements so inside of the
div it's going to be the box shadows
within the element rather than on the
outside casting a shadow behind it it's
going to be inside the element itself
the first number here the first value is
the horizontal the horizontal offset and
that's if you put a positive number like
five pixels it's going to be shift to
the right if you put negative five it's
going to go shift it to the left so at
zero it's dead center the second one is
the vertical offset so positive number
like five pixels is going to be shifted
down and if you put a negative number
like negative five it's going to be
shifted up and then the second the third
number here is the the blur radius and
that's how blurry you want that box
shadow zero would mean a sharp line and
like ten pixels would be a blurry box
shadow depending on the effect you want
and the this one is the spread radius so
if you want it to be a really big you
know the the box shut up to spread then
you'd have a higher number if you don't
want to do anything than zero these are
the only two that are required these two
are optional values that you don't need
to put and so then the last one is the
color of the shadow so if I say this
head over here you're gonna see just the
thin hair line in the browser and that's
what we've created just a thin little
blue hair line and that's all we wanted
all right so next what I want is to
change the background to it's gonna be
four to six seven B to just for the
background color border:solid 1px ol
same color as the previous color there
that's the face book bluey purple color
color of the text
is gonna just be white text shadow let's
go four zero one pixel zero and then
three three five nine a five and that's
just gonna be you know a little bit
darker of a text shadow under the white
text so let's have a look and see what
that looks like over in the browser if I
save that button looks good
got that slight border a little bit of a
glow on the top as if a light was
shining down on the button to give it a
little bit of depth white text slight
text shadow and under there beautiful it
looks great now we don't have any hover
or active effects when you interact with
the button so let's do that over here in
the code editor I'm gonna go down a
couple spaces and tab in one that's not
gonna change the CSS at all it's just
for organization I like having my
related rules to be organized in a
manner that I can see so if I tab in I
know that this rule that I'm doing so
face book style dark and then hover I
know that this rule is directly related
to this rule right here whereas these
two are not as related they're kind of
you know it's more so for my own
organization purposes so you can do what
you want but this is what I like to do
feel free to follow along in that manner
alright so on the hover what I want to
do is change the background color to to
be five for a seven and I save that and
then we're gonna copy this and paste it
and change the hover to active so that
what I'm going to do here is I'm going
to change the background to one D four
six nine eight and then the border color
to the same save that now if I go over
here and interact with that button hover
a little bit darker click an active
state a little bit darker still the
border is dark looks great all right
let's style up that light button over
there so I head back to our code editor
here a couple returns there let's go
face book style a light and I'm gonna
say the background is
f6 f7 f9 the border is going to be solid
1 pixel C D OD 4 0 D for the border
radius we already covered that the color
the text color is going to be 4 B 4 F 5
6 I believe that's right yeah that's
like a gray and then the padding is good
so that's all we need to do for the
light button let's check it out
it looks good much more minimal and
simple I like that style and now what we
need to do is add the hover and active
States for that button as well so a
couple of returns down tab it in face
book style light hover and all we're
going to do is change the background to
be 90 B EE and then we're gonna copy
this whole rule and change this one to
active and then we're just going to
change the background to d8 da de copy
that and what we're gonna do is change
the border color to the same save that
check it out interact with it hover a
little bit darker click darker still
looks great I like it alright so those
are the Facebook style buttons we're
going to be coding the 3d CSS 3 buttons
we're still in the fancy buttons section
of the course day 1 but we're gonna do
the 3d buttons now so here in the
browser you can see the two 3-d buttons
that were gonna be styling up so let's
just do that go to our code editor I'm
gonna add a CSS comment flag here so we
know where we are so the 3d button you
can do what you want you could do a
simpler comment if you want this is what
I like to do keeps it nice and easy to
organize and read so what we're going to
be doing now is we're going to be
selecting 3d buttons here we're gonna be
doing the button 3d one I mean if I go
up here actually button 3d 1 + button 3d
- that's what we're gonna be selecting
so let's go ahead and select button a 3d
1 and that is going to select that first
3d button we're going to style that
position:relative important because
we're going to be doing a little bit of
movement background is gonna be orange
red nice and simple no border color of
the text is gonna be white padding to me
15 pixels 15 pixels top and bottom 24
pixels on the left and the right the
font size we're gonna do 1.4 REM when
you're using em it's relative to the
parent element whereas when you're using
RAM it's relative to the root so it's
just more consistent it's a nice little
measurement for css3 box-shadow
for for this we're gonna do box shadow
we're gonna say negative 6 pixels 6
pixels 0 locust that's 5 pixels 0 and
then we're gonna do HSL for
hue/saturation in little whatever
lattice HSL so 16 100% and then 30
percent 16 is the hue 100 is the
saturation and then 30 percent is the
lightness so we want it to be this kind
of like blood-red sort of color for the
shadow and then the outline we want no
outline if I save that and we head over
to our sandbox here you can see we have
the 3d button it has the shadow over
here but the thing is if I look at the
final version it has it has this kind of
corner that connects the two so while
that looks pretty cool I want it to be
connected so we're gonna go ahead and
work with that here in a moment but
before we do that we might as well while
we're here let's do the hover the hover
and active States button 3d one hover
we're gonna do background is going to be
HSL 16 100% and then 40% I got these
colors from Photoshop by the way if
you're wondering I'm not just pulling
them out of the top of my head top
pixels top 3 pixels left negative 3
pixels this is why it was important to
do position:relative so that we can
position the elements based on when we
hover it so and then the box shadow
we're going to change it a little bit to
negative 3 pixels 3 pixels 0 and then
HSL the same here so what that's going
to do is when you click it lets or when
you hover it let's check it out
see how it pops down that's pretty cool
actually I don't want that to do it on
however I want that to do it on active
so that's going to actually be the
active State and now above this I want
to do the button 3d hover a button 3d
one hover and that's going to be simple
we're just going to change the
background to HSL 16 145 for lightness
so it's gonna be a little bit lighter so
hover it's actually it's actually little
bit darker so there we go and when we
click it moves that button down so cool
now what we want to do is you want to
give those corners we want to we want to
add those little corners to connect
these two so it gives the illusion that
they are one entire uniform box so we
can do that by doing the before let me
show you here so we're gonna do three
button 3d one and then two colons makes
it go before it's like a virtual it's
like a pseudo element of the here we go
creates a pseudo element that is the
first child that the element matched so
it creates a pseudo element that it's
not actually on in the markup but it
allows us to basically create an element
of a thin air that's connected to this
dip so what we're going to do is we're
going to use that before pseudo element
position it absolute this is where the
magic happens it's pretty cool
display:block content we need to do this
in order to it for it to appear on the
screen it needs to have the content and
an empty string you can put text in
there too if you want which we'll do at
some point height:0 width:0 what we're
gonna be doing is creating a triangle
and putting it in that corner there so
if I were to save this now you're not
gonna see anything so there's no point
in showing you what we're gonna do is
create a border now and let's see this
is gonna be solid six pixels
transparent what is that word
transparent now the border width needs
to be the size of the elements box
shadow so the box shadow here you could
see it here so we only have six pixels
so we have six pixels up here so you'll
see why in a moment and we're gonna do
border
whoops border right solid six pixels HSL
we're gonna do that color there 16 130
now I'm gonna say this I'm gonna show
you over here in the browser look at
this right here you can see this little
triangle that we made do you see that so
it's just appearing here and the width
in the button so you can see what we've
made so far so we've made that and what
we want to do is basically pull that up
into the corner so we can use a section
of it to give the illusion that there's
a connection between that between the
button and its shadow so let's go back
here in our code editor we're gonna say
border left with zero pixels and what
that's going to do is if we go back over
here all it's done is moved the element
over about six pixels so if I were to
comment this out and save it and watch
here in the browser as a refresh so you
do back over its just when I add zero as
the border left width it has no border
here so technically
the whole element is this big 12 pixels
but I want it to be just this six pixels
right here so I'm saying border left
width or here in the code editor is zero
it just cleans it up a little bit so
that doesn't mess with my measurements
when we move it background:none
sometimes there's a background in the
way I don't think I need to do that now
what I'm going to do is say the top is
zero pixels that's gonna push it over
here in the browser to the top of the
element and now I need to push it over
and fit it in right here like a puzzle
piece like Tetris and the left if I were
to say left zero what that's going to do
is just put it over here in the browser
just gonna put it to the left here so I
need it to be all the way over here and
that if we know our math when we set
that element up there is negative six or
six pixels wide so this needs to be
negative six pixels so the left needs to
be negative six if I save that it's
gonna put it over there check out what
just happened a little bit of magic
gives the illusion that that element is
connected just by creating a little css3
triangle with borders and moving it with
positioning into that corner right here
to give the illusion it's just it's just
cool okay so we're gonna do the same
thing for that bottom right corner but
because we've already used that before
pseudo element we need to use the after
pseudo element so we have access to that
as well so I'm gonna copy I'm gonna copy
this because much of it is the same and
I'm all I'm gonna do is paste it change
it to after but we need to change the
position of certain parts of the element
so we can't just have it be the same
because it's just going to show up in
the same top left corner so we need to
change it a little bit so it's actually
me let me remove all of this right here
except for the border saw the
transparent what we're gonna do now is
going to say border top there's gonna be
solid six pixels and then we have that
HSL we're gonna copy that color
like so border a bottom width whoops is
zero pixels so now if I say that come
over here and you could see all we're
doing now is the border you can see
imagine this as a box it's actually a
whole box and I'm displaying only the
top section of the border so there's no
there's no size to the box there's
nothing in the Dave at all at the height
is zero and the width is zero but the
border itself is six pixels wide so
we've got a six pixel border on all
sides one two three four this is the top
all I'm doing is hiding the left right
and the bottom borders and only showing
the top border so it has this triangle
effect so it's a cool little illusion
that you could do in css3 so the the
border top is six pixels and the border
bottom is gonna be zero and the also you
can see here the border transparent all
the borders are transparent so if I were
to remove the border top overwrite and
then go back here in the browser refresh
you can see it's gone because the border
is transparent but six pixels wide but
now if I change the border top which is
the one I want to show to solid so we
could see it six pixels and give it a
color save it now it's going to show and
then the border bottom width I'm just
making it zero so that it collapses so
it doesn't give us this messy you know
twelve pixel box but all I need is six
pixels does that make sense I hope it
does it's quite simple and awesome
that's a pretty cool little concept to
create css3 triangles okay so we've done
that now all we need to do is we need to
move it so the right is gonna be zero so
it's all the way over to the right so as
you can see in the browser if I were to
save this it's gonna pop over all I need
to do now is move it down all the way to
the bottom so let's go here we're gonna
go bottom negative six pixels in the
browser pop over here look at that it
moved it all the way to the bottom now
we have this effect that it's connected
it's quite magical cool okay now we have
one little thing that we need to fix
here if I were to click on this watch
what happens
it's gonna move the whole element but
now we can see our little triangles so
that's a problem so what we need to do
now is when we on the hover on the
active states of the before and after
pseudo elements we need to shrink those
triangles so that it still gives the
effect to the illusion that it's a full
box so that's quite simple all we need
to do is add a couple extra things here
I'm gonna say button 3d one active and
then before so this means when it's
active I want to select the before
pseudo-element
and we're going to change the border to
solid three pixels rather than six
pixels because it needs to be the size
of the border width transparent perfect
the border right is going to be solid
three pixels it's gonna be that HSL up
here copying that pasting that and then
the border left width is going to be
three zero pixels although I don't know
if we necessarily need to do that so I'm
just going to remove that because I've
already declared it and then left is
going to be negative three pixels rather
than negative six pixels if I save that
and now watch this the left side well
that doesn't look good at all okay
something went weird there maybe I do
need to to declare the border left width
to zero let's see what that does
so I needed to do the border left with
to zero for some reason and now that
looks good but the bottom one doesn't
look good so let's just copy all this
and then paste it below we're gonna
change it to the after a pseudo element
border is gonna be solid three pixels
the border top is gonna be solid three
pixels and then the border bottom width
is gonna be zero and then the bottom is
going to be negative three
save that check it out in the browser
now we've got a perfectly working 3d
button with all of the corners and the
triangles working perfectly in sync
awesome
that is beautiful all right now let's do
these the second 3d button here the
circle looks a little bit like this it's
a circle it's got a radial gradient when
you've got this back here this kind of
depth to it so when you it looks like
it's
hopping off the the background and then
when you click it it kind of sinks into
it and it's a cool 3d effect so we're
gonna create that button right now pop
over to your code editor and now I'm
gonna add that comment flag for 3d
button number two so I know where I am
okay and first thing I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna select that button so it's the
class of BTN - 3d - - we're gonna start
off saying position:relative because
we're going to be doing a little bit of
positioning so if we need that to have
something declared a fallback background
we're gonna change have it be kind of
like a yellow ECD 300 and then that's
just gonna be default yellow but we're
gonna want to add some radial gradients
so we're gonna also declare another
background and then we're gonna say
WebKit radial gradient and this requires
two values you could say like red comma
blue and then it will look something
like this over here in the browser you
can see pretty ugly radial gradient but
that's how the radial gradient works
we're gonna be declaring a few these are
browser prefixes I'm going to do WebKit
Oh Moz and then just the fallback
standard syntax so we'll get there so
instead of red and blue we're gonna do
something a little bit more complicated
we're just gonna be using HSL again for
hue saturation saturation and lightness
the hue is 50 for 100 percent for the
saturation so fully saturated and 50
percent in terms of lightness so
slightly dark not 100 percent like white
not zero like black we just wanted to be
in the middle and then I'm gonna do
another HSL all right through the same
color the same hue and saturation but
different lightness 40 percents so I'm
gonna copy this paste based based change
the first the second browser prefix to
the letter O for opera and the third one
to Moz for Mozilla and the last one just
removed the prefix altogether that's the
standard syntax that right there is
going to give you a radial gradient
check it over and your browser looks a
little bit like that nice fine and dandy
beauty let's move down back here in a
code editor on size we're gonna say one
point for RIM and then we're gonna go
ahead and do some
text shadows and that's going to be 0
negative 1 pixel 0 and then see 3 8 0 7
what's that negative 1 pixel do that's
the vertical offset for the text shadow
so if I had a positive number like 1
pixel the tech shadow would be one pixel
below the text but a negative value like
negative 1 is one pixel above the text
so I want the shadow to be above the
text and 0 here is the ability that's
the horizontal axis offset Tori and this
is the blur the third value is the blur
I don't want any blur and I want any
horizontal offset I just want negative 1
vertical offset so that it's slightly
above the text and then a slightly
lighter a more white yellow than what is
on the background you'll see the effect
that that gives shortly color of the
text is going to be white border:solid
1px ol I've got that HSL again we're
gonna do 50 for 100 percent and 20
percent so a little bit dark and then we
got the border radius that's gonna be
100 percent for a full circle height 120
pixels width 120 pixels
zette index 4 because we're gonna be
playing with some positioning of the set
index because we're gonna have that
background behind it we want to make
sure it's above you know there's a
method to my madness okay so zetta index
4 and now let's check it out in the
browser perfect circle looks great you
could see the text here look at the text
shadow you can see that slight dark
yellow it looks like this circle text is
indented within the element so that's
what that effect gives it versus the
Facebook button we did up here where the
text shadow is below it makes it look
like it pops off the button this one I
wanted to make it look like it's in the
button a little bit like it's uh you
know you take like a stamp like it's
stamped inside of it okay now we're
gonna do watch this when I click this it
has this gnarly looking outline
no outline doesn't let me do
border-radius so we're just gonna room
move the outline pop over to the code
editor outline:none gone I don't usually
like to remove outlines for
accessibility reasons but in this case
it's gone we're gonna do something else
all right we're gonna do some box
shadows we're gonna create this effect
right here over in the browser it gives
this cascading effect that makes it look
like it's lifted off in the background
we're gonna do that right now with a
bunch of box shadows so let's go back to
the code editor and start off with box
shadow I'm not gonna do the browser
prefixes cuz box shadow is pretty widely
accepted and I don't want to write this
out so many times so box shadow we're
gonna start with an inset 0 1 pixels 0
HSL 54 100% and 50% and if I left it at
that that's going to give us this slight
hairline above it making it look like
the light is shining down from above and
giving it a little bit of a depth looks
nice cool thing is I can add more I can
add more than one line to this box
shadow instead of writing box shadow box
shadow box shadow like that which I
don't even know if will work you can
actually just separate the values with a
comma go to a new line just for
readability purposes and add another
value for the box shadow style so that's
cool so we're gonna do not inset from
the second one two pixels zero HSL you
guessed it 50 for 100 percent and 20
percent now what we're going to do here
is we're going to copy this line and
separated by comma paste it change a
couple values three pixels for the next
one and take off a couple percent you'll
be able to see a pattern here
sixteen percent separated by comma this
is going to be six pixels this is going
to be fourteen percent this one is going
to be seven pixels oops this four five
six pixels and this is going to be
twelve percent seven pixels ten percent
just a couple more
eight pixels eight percent and this
one's gonna be nine pixels and then six
percent it basically goes to black end
it with a semicolon save that check it
out over here in the browser you get
that cool effect
it looks pretty pretty cool you can see
what happens just adding more box shadow
values it's just giving that effect it's
gradually going to a darker that gives
the illusion that it's kind of
three-dimensional pretty cool now what
we're going to do is when we hover and
click on it we're gonna give it some
some Styles so I'm gonna go over here to
my CSS tab it in not final sorry BTN -
3d - to hover we're going to change the
radial gradient so I'm just going to
copy it up here
I'm gonna leave the fallback I don't
need to change that if you want you can
and I'm gonna change the radial
gradients all around so that when you
hover it changes the color of it
so HSL 54 100 that's gonna stay the same
but we're gonna change the lightness to
45 on here and 35 on there
copy that the two HSL values paste them
in each of the styles here save you
typing save that check it out in the
browser is your going to hover it's
going to work beauty beautiful e and
then now what we're gonna do is on the
active state we're going to change the
radial gradient as well copy all that
and then change hover to active and
we're going to change the values from 45
to 43 and 35 to 333 copy both of those
paste them in each of the lines here to
save you some typing just like that cool
and now we'll just check it out so here
in the browser hover active hover active
default hover active looks good
okay now below these lines here we're
going to do top two pixels we're going
to bump it down two pixels when we click
on it
now watch what happens over here in the
browser click pops down two pixels but
there's a problem it moves the entire
element down I only want to remember to
move the foreground down two pixels not
the box-shadow so how did we do that
because here you can see we kind of do a
similar thing it almost sinks into the
button like you're clicking you know
clicking the button so it sinks down so
that's what we want to do here with the
circle we don't want to move the
background the that part we want to move
just the top so how do we do that
easy over here in your active CSS rule
we're just going to copy that box shadow
that we did appear and all we're going
to do because we need to account for two
pixels that were bumping down all we
need to do is remove the last two
lines of box-shadow I place that last
one with semicolon save it and now
because we've taken to those out that
was two pixels it's going to accommodate
this clique
all right now we're gonna mess around
with these gradient bordered buttons
right here you can see we got this one
kind of this orange e red to yellow from
the bottom right bottom left hand corner
up and to the right hand corner there
you could see the point here is that the
border has a gradient on it and then
when you hover you get the gradient on
the inside but the point here is that
you can make borders have gradients
which is cool and then the second
example we actually have this I don't
know if it's necessarily practical but
its just a cool practice something just
to show you what you can do is you can
actually have the border fade out so we
have it from going left to right and
then it just fades out kind of into
nothing and then when you hover the
background does the same so why don't we
jump in and do that over in our code
editor sandbox at CSS we're gonna go
ahead and add that CSS comment just like
so gradient bordered buttons you can do
something simpler if you want I just
like doing that alright so we're gonna
check out in the index of HTML what is
one of this classes that we're working
with we've got a gradient button one
gradient button two beauty okay so
gradient button - one we're gonna start
off and give it a position of relative
oh that's weird that's not what we want
relative and then Zed index one just to
keep it all at one level just in case we
have some weird stuff going on with
overlaps and stuff put
display:inline-block padding:0 forty
forty pixels and then we're gonna say
font size let's go for one point for RIM
box sizing is gonna be border box so
that the twenty and forty pixels it
doesn't add more width and height to the
button when we add a thick border to it
that stays within the constraints of the
dimensions that we set I'm rid of a
background color e7e ef-1 and that's
just a background color
and then we're gonna do a border of
solid ten pixels and transparent so
we're gonna give it it's gonna be solid
and ten pixels but no color because
we're gonna we're gonna add that here
using border image we're gonna do the
linear gradient and then parentheses
then we have a couple few values here so
we're gonna say two top right which
means it's coming from the bottom left
and moving up to the top right that's
what that means you could also say two
bottom right - top left - you know
bottom left or you could just say top
right bottom or left and have it be
linear you know have it go from the top
to the bottom left to the right all this
does is it goes up on an angle and
that's what I want to be able to achieve
here and then we need to have some
colors the first color I'm gonna go with
orange red and then the second yellow
and then if I save that let's see what
that looks like okay so we've got each
of the corners have that gradient so it
kind of looks weird it's not really what
we want from but it has the color so
from bottom left to top right it's got
that orange red to yellow so the
gradients right but it's just popping
into the corners now the way we fix that
is using a CSS property called border
image slice basically it specifies how
to slice the image so you can use the
border image and put an actual image as
the border but I'm using a gradient so I
found that if we put if we go back here
to our code editor and if we were to put
the border image slice now you could put
different values in there but the the
value that I'm going to put is literally
just the number one and what that does
is it fills out so that each of those
corners connect that's what that does
you can also play around with different
values and see what happens and there's
also different things like fill and so
on and so forth you can read about it in
the browser support but border image
slice one connects all those corners and
so there we got our gradients and
essentially essentially it's done that's
gradient button you know gradient border
button
but I just want to make it a little bit
more interactive it doesn't really look
like a button all right and then color
let's make the text color orange red as
well and then we're gonna say transition
this is just for when we have a little
bit of an effect to hover effect 0.3
seconds he's in out I like that one you
can use ease you can use linear you can
use quad ease in or whatever there's a
bunch of different transition properties
so transition ease in out works fine for
me but you won't see it until we use it
on the hover so we're going to tab in
here we're gonna say gradient button -
one and that's gonna be hover and we're
just gonna say
background-image:linear-gradient we're
going to litter your gradient as well
and then to top right and we're just
gonna fill out the same style gradient
orange red comma yellow that's what that
will get you save that check it out here
when I hover it's going to give us that
gradient in the background and then
let's say color white save that check it
out it should look pretty good there
when you hover the the text color slowly
fades into white from the orange red and
then the background pops in there
filling in that gradient so that looks
pretty cool the point here was the
gradient border around the button itself
okay so now let's jump down to a
gradient button - let's do that one real
quick here so we're gonna do gradient
button - - and we're gonna do
position:relative is that index one that
should do the trick
padding let's see we just copy a lot of
this actually why don't we just hey
folks let's save some time copy all this
goodness gracious all we're gonna do is
just paste that in there we're not doing
anything new or crazy it
or maybe let's change the size of the
border so instead of 10 pixels just make
it like four pixels and the colors let's
do orange red to transparent but right
now because we're doing two top right
it's not what I want I want it to go too
right so orange red to transparent so
it's gonna fade out leave the color and
the transition there and then we're
gonna copy the hover as well because we
need that for interactive kind of
accessibility reasons it's gonna be
button to gradient button too and this
is gonna be too right this is gonna be
too transparent and that should do the
trick let's see what happens save it
check it out in your browser looks good
so far when I hover whoops what's going
on there a border shows up on the right
side what we need to do on hover is
remove that border so let's go back to
our code editor and simply say border
right style none that should do the
trick
go back here hover perfect there you go
so we have great a border but in one in
gradient border button two very simple
nice little trick using border images
and linear gradients I like it alright
now let's do these animated buttons here
you can see the first example animated
button we got a background pattern and
then when you hover it just kind of
slightly animates you know from you know
from the left to the right and
continually goes infinitely until you
just kind of take your mouse off the off
the button you use that you know this is
just a simple example you can do
anything from gradients to background
patterns to background images you know
to when you hover over a button you
could do different interactions but this
is just an idea just to give you so that
you can you know play with it and see
what you can come up with it yourself in
your own sights animated about number
two is simply just playing with playing
with padding so it's a little bit of an
illusion so it looks like this actually
animates from from the right towards the
left and then the Chevron comes in from
the right but really it's just a play on
padding and then some transitions and
stuff so we'll get to that here so let's
jump into our sandbox
I'm just gonna add my CSS comment flag
so we know where we are at alright so
we've got our animated buttons comment
flag let's start off find out the index
file here what are these the classes
that we use here animated buttons
animated button one and two perfect
simple animated button - one let's start
off position:relative and then we're
gonna go display:inline-block we're
gonna add some padding and then say Oh
20 pixels top and bottom 40 pixels left
and right font size suit 1.4 rim and
then background color
double-o b3 b4 it's like that green teal
blue thing color
alright background image I've got a
shape and on a JPEG a PNG file here
pattern dot PNG it's 40 by 40 pixels
it's just a pattern I got online from a
site origin com it's just a pattern
generator website and I'm gonna throw in
a URL there simply just grab pattern dot
PNG because it's in the same directory
as the CSS Beauty background size we're
gonna go for 40 pixels by 40 pixels the
border of the button itself let's just
go for solid one pixel triple 5 just to
give it a little bit of I don't know
definition color white
transition we're gonna go all ease 0.3
seconds and now if we save that and
check it out it's gonna look like this
you're gonna have your pattern here but
hovering doesn't do anything so let's go
ahead and fix that so what we're gonna
do is under this animated button we're
gonna go animated button one hover and
then we're gonna do animation animation
and say well we have to call a name of
an animation so we have to create an
animation in a keyframe right after this
but what we're gonna do is we're gonna
call the animation loading button
animation it's gonna go over two seconds
it's gonna be linear animation so it's
not gonna have like an ease in out it's
just gonna be a linear movement and
infinite never stops so now what we need
to do is create the keyframes so what
I'm gonna do here is go ahead and go
down just below I'm gonna call this
keyframes well that's what you have to
call it keyframes a CSS animation and I
have to give it a name it's gonna be
loading button animation this is the
name of the animation it can be whatever
you want it to be and then nice and
simple we're just gonna say from and
then return print curly braces here
background position zero and zero and
then after this we're gonna go to and
then the background position is going to
be 40 pixels zero all right so now if we
save this let's see what happens
hover it moves Beauty it looks great so
and then you stop it stops cool so that
is the loading button animation for a
number one and now what we're gonna do
is I'm going to go below this one here
and I'm going to style up the animated
button too now what we're going to do
here
we're going to basically have the same
sort of
base styles as animated about number one
so I'm just gonna copy everything here
paste it in but I am going to not have
the pattern we don't need the pattern
it's just gonna have the color now if I
save this let's check it out it should
look pretty much the same cool
this one has animation this one doesn't
okay and now what we're gonna do is
we're going to create that chevron that
pops in on the right so we need to
declare after this animated button - -
and this will be after a pseudo element
position is absolute top 50% is where
we're gonna position it so in the center
and from the right we could just do like
you do any measurement could be 20
pixels it could be you know 1m I'm gonna
do 0.6 m and we're gonna say content now
this is where you want to put the
content of the what you want to appear
so we can have it be text we can say hi
and then the letters you know H and I
will pop in but we want it to be the
Chevron so I just copied a Chevron into
my clipboard you can do an arrow you can
do any you know you can you could just
do like this you know you can do
whatever it is you want but if you want
the Chevron in the final CSS you could
just go down to line 300 ish and then
copy the Chevron and paste it into here
alright and and then after that we're
going to transition all ease 0.3 seconds
and now let's see what this does so far
so it shows up here so 50% apparently
doesn't quite get it in the right
position so we can play with the top
over here in the code editor do
something like 30% and that will bring
it up a little bit to make it look like
it's in the center there we go that'll
do and now we want to do is set the
opacity
to zero we don't want it to appear at
first we want it to be totally invisible
and now what we want to do is when we
hover we want to ship this text over to
the left so we'll do that by removing
some left padding adding some right
padding so it looks like so that looks
like the width of the button stays the
same just the text shifts over and
because we have a transition it will
glide over rather than jump over and
we'll have the Chevron appear in with
opacity 100 or 1 for a hundred percent
so let's go below here and simply say
animated button number to hover and
we're gonna do something like padding
and 20 pixels 60 pixels on the right
which is 20 pixels more than usual 20 on
the bottom and then 20 on the left which
is I believe 20 pixels less than usual
so 60s actually it's normally 2040 2040
so we're doing 2060 2020 so it's going
to give the illusion of the same width
but the text sliding over and what we're
gonna do now is add in that after
pseudo-element
so animated button to hover and then the
after pseudo-element it's gonna be right
we're gonna move it in from the right
we're gonna change it to something like
1.2 m rather than 0.6 m so double the
the distance and then opacity will be 1
save that let's check it out let's hover
over that button boom look at that it
slides over it looks like the Chevron is
sliding in and the text is sliding over
to accommodate it and that's the
illusion we're giving but really what's
happening is that we're changing the
padding on the left and the right I'm
making the chevron appear just by
changing those measurements but because
we have transition
it's actually animating those padding
adjustments giving the illusion that
we're sliding the text over and sliding
in the chevron from thin air so it's
pretty cool effect and then this one is
that sliding background pattern alright
so now we're going to code up these
toggle switch UI buttons now I want to
show you something a little interesting
about this these buttons are different
or these switches are different than the
previous examples these up here are just
buttons over so we're actually using
button tags let me show you here in the
HTML right here you could see all these
examples are actually button tags
whereas down here and the toggle switch
UI buttons we're actually using labels
wrapping the entire thing then we have
an input and then a span so this input
is a checkbox input and we're using that
to toggle we're going to be using that
to tell CSS you know when the checkbox
is toggled to checked and unchecked and
so let's go back over here to the
browser and if I go up to the sandbox
you're gonna see toggle switch uui
buttons so they're actually just
checkboxes so this one's the click me to
activate one and this one is just the
toggle so we're going to be using CSS to
manipulate the the view of this checkbox
into an actual switch this is what's
cool about css3 is you could do really
cool things like this you could take an
element itself and completely transform
it into something totally different to
serve the purpose of your website or
your application so let's jump into our
code editor again we're gonna go to our
sandbox and let's go right to the bottom
here below our last bit of code animated
buttons I'm gonna put a new CSS comment
up here this is the toggle switch UI
buttons okay and now let's get started
we're gonna start off with the toggle
buttons and other classes that we're
using here jump into our HTML you're
gonna see if I go up here right here
toggle class is toggle one toggle one
input and toggle one button and then
toggle two uses the same naming
conventions just with toggle two alright
so let's jump in here we're gonna start
off and say toggle dash 1 and let's
we're gonna start off because this is
not a button it's not grabbing the
Helvetica font family that we've been
using it's falling
back to the body's font-family which is
like Roboto or something so we're gonna
change the font family and override that
to a simple Helvetica Arial and then
sans-serif just a nice simple font stack
display:inline-block we're gonna need to
use that vertical-align:top this is just
some housekeeping right here margin:0
oops
zero 15 pixels zero zero save that if i
go over here to my browser you're gonna
see you just kind of went a little bit
wonky you know this one's now lined up
to the top that's what we want we want
everything to be consistent so that when
we're working we're working across all
the browsers from a similar state
whereas when I don't have vertical line
top and the margins and the
display:inline-block some browsers
interpret you know a default checkbox
style in different ways so we want to
remove those inconsistencies and kind of
start from the same place that's what we
just did there back to our code editor
now let's go below that all we're gonna
do here is they're gonna tab in one and
I'm gonna say toggle one now I'm gonna
select so double underscore input that's
the CSS class that we used and all I'm
gonna say is display:none so I want to
remove that input all together I don't
want to see it because now what I want
to do is below that so that will make
that input disappear what I want to do
now is select the toggle - one button so
that's actually the span tag that's a
sibling of the input this is where the
magic happens we're going to style that
up to look like a toggle switch so we're
going to go position whoops
position:relative we're gonna say
display:inline-block we're going to go
font size 14 pixels or actually that's
be better about that one RIM because
that's the default route body size 14
pixels I believe line height 20 pixels
text transform we want that to be
uppercase
and background-color let's do something
like f two three nine five a and then
the border we're gonna do solid one
pixel seam value is up here border okay
now we're doing color white we're gonna
do the width of the switch itself is
going to be eighty pixels height is 30
pixels we want that to be hard coded
transition I'm going to do all
point zero point three seconds and then
ease just something simple and if you
want you could do browser prefixes for
that you can also check out the can I
use website at the bottom of all each
lesson there's a link there to the can I
use website where you could type in the
CSS property you want to see if that's
cross browser compatible and what
different prefixes you need to use but
I'm just gonna use the default one
because whatever and the cursor I don't
need to do that and I did that default
already I believe no this is a span so I
need to do cursor:pointer because the
span tag doesn't do a default cursor
Mario hand this one but the glove I
don't know if that was offensive to
somebody but we want to make it look
like a button so we need the interaction
to behave like a button which gives us
the Mario hand Mario glove
cursor:pointer okay that should just
really be cursor Mario glove you know
what I mean pointer okay enough about
that okay so now what are we just pop
over here to the browser check out what
we got so far so now we got the
background of that switch so let's keep
going back here in the code editor now
what we're gonna do select the toggle
one button before pseudo elements we're
gonna create something and we're gonna
create something out of nothing out of
thin air position:absolute when you're
when you're working with a pseudo
element you want it to appear you need
to absolute position it you need to give
it a Content which we're gonna get to so
let's go well content let's make it say
off we want it to say off a lot of the
time we'll just do an empty string but
let's just say off or we're gonna go
display:inline-block and it'll height 20
pixels padding zero and three pixels on
the left and the right background color
want it to be white so we could see it
on that kind of that rip that salmony
color not farm salmon fresh salmon
there's a difference
color is going to be the f2 it's going
to be that F 2 3 9 5a that's the salmony
color where do you do the content let's
do transition is going to be all 0.3
seconds ease and now let's save it and
see what we got let's see what we can
see alright so here is in the browser
you can see the off it's right there
it's not centered so we're gonna Center
that just by doing some positioning just
to roughly Center it so let's do that
after position I like doing my top six
pixel right after the position because
it's related and then left 40 pixels
because it's off I want it to be far
over to the right so let's see where
that puts it perfect almost dead center
it's a lick looks like it could maybe do
like top 5 pixels over here let's go
back to the browser's check it out that
looks a bit better to me cool so off the
off switches there doesn't work yet but
it will
so now what we want to do is this when I
touch this this element is a span tag
but what I want to be able to do is when
I click it let me click it with my mouse
I want it to well here let's go to our
index what's gonna happen is when I
click on the label because see how the
label here is wrapping everything
because we're using the four attribute
here it's looking for four toggle one
which is the ID toggle one so it's
looking for the input which is hidden
but it still will interact normally so
when I click on the label it's going to
toggle that input because of this four
attribute connecting it to the ID right
here
so that means when I'm clicking this
label the input is still the checkbox is
toggling from on to off CSS can access
that can find out if the input the
checkbox is being toggled on and off and
then we can manipulate the style based
on if it's honored to off this where the
magic happens so let's go back to the
sandbox and what we're gonna do now is
we're going to say toggle one input
checked so it's gonna match it's gonna
basically style the checked version so
this is selecting the checked version of
the of the input of the check box but I
don't actually want to style that
checkbox because I can't see it I want
to select its sibling it's direct
sibling immediately after it which is
the span tag so we use that with the
adjacent sibling selector it's a
Combinator so it come by its it allows
me to look for the input that's checked
but select its direct sibling which is
going to be the toggle - one underscore
button so I'm selecting that but only if
this is check see what's happening there
I'm going to say background color or our
background
change it to zero zero B 3 B 4 and the
border I'm going to change to solid one
pixel the same color now when I save
that let's see what happens when I click
see it's change in the background color
so when it's checked the checkbox is
checked it is changed in the background
color and now it's not check now all I
need to do is have that this switch
change to on to move over to the left so
back in our code editor we can do that
really easily by selecting the toggle
one input checked the adjacent sibling
selector we're going to select toggle
one button but the before pseudo-element
the one that is this one right here this
before selector we're going to select
that when this is checked and we're
going to modify the style so we're going
to change the position to left 5 pixels
rather than 40 and we're going to say
content is gonna change to on rather
than off and the color of the text is
going to be 0 0 b3 b4 save that now
watch the magic here in the browser
click the toggle switch BAM
slides over just like that the position
content and color change turn it off
slides back over just like that beauty
looks really really good I might even
change the position here just like a
little bit of a detail let's do left
I don't know 38 see what that looks like
that looks better to me all right now
let's go to this next toggle switch GUI
button right here that clicked me to
activate one what we're gonna do here
it's a similar it's essentially the same
markup the same HTM our cup so you could
see here when I click on the label it
toggles the check box which is what
we're going to use in css3 to to kind of
manipulate the visual so over here in a
code editor let's go down to sandbox CSS
and let's keep coding the next toggle
button so the class is toggle - - and
let's just do some housekeeping so font
family a Helvetica arial sans-serif and
then we're gonna do the font size is
gonna let's do one rim actually let's
make it smaller
let's do 0.8 rim make it small a little
bit a little bit smaller
display:inline-block and then we're
gonna do vertical align is gonna be top
margin 0 5 15 pixels 0 0 and then let's
keep going so in under toggle to tab and
in one just for organization toggle - to
double underscore inputs now we're going
to select that actual input this is the
checkbox input and we're going to hide
that display:none we don't want to see
it and then and under that we're going
to do toggle - - double underscore
button now we're selecting that span tag
that is the adjacent sibling to the
input we're gonna do position:relative
we're gonna do display:inline-block line
height - 20 pixels should do it a trick
text transform uppercase background is
gonna be white we're gonna change the
color to triple-a and the borders and we
solid one pixel triple see
Hadding let's do five pixels in the top
10 on the right 5 on the bottom 30 on
the left you'll see why in a moment and
then transition we're gonna do the same
we were doing for all of them is all 0.3
seconds and then just ease
cursor:pointer because this is a span
tag we need to a we need it to behave
like a button so we need the mario the
mario glove save that let's check it out
what it looks like in the browser click
me to activate cool beautiful very
simple kind of whites it's got that thin
hair line on the outside 30 pixels on
the left side of padding this is gonna
allow us to create a little element
there to just make it look a little bit
more interesting so maybe down here I'll
show you we got a little square we're
gonna play with that okay so back here
in the code editor let's let's go toggle
to button before pseudo-element
we're going to position:absolute top 10
pixels left 10 pixels and we're gonna do
display:inline-block we're gonna say
width is 10 pixels heights is 10 pixels
the background I'm gonna be triple C
content is going to be just an empty
string so that we can actually see the
before pseudo-element and the transition
is going to be all zero point three
seconds
ease save that let's see what it looks
like here in the browser just a simple
square let's do something more
interesting and make it a circle so what
we got to do here is just add in the CSS
border radius 100% alternatively you
could do 10 pixels because we know the
fixed width and height but I just like
100% because if we change the the width
and the height of the element then the
border radius 100% will cover our bases
that's gonna give us a nice circle over
here in the browser beauty I like it
alright and now what we're gonna do is
go back to our code editor below that
we're gonna style up the we're going to
select the checked state of the input
because we click that label it turns on
the check box we're gonna select that
but we're gonna select its with the
adjacent sibling selector we're going to
select the
the span tag that is the adjacent
sibling so that we can style it so we're
gonna do toggle dash to input this is
the checked state
and then the adjacent sibling selector
toggle - - button and then the before
pseudo-element we're selecting this
thing right here when the checkbox has
been checked and we're going to style
that up by saying the background is
going to change to double O B 3 B 4 the
border color is going to change to the
same color and the color of the text
will be white
and let's save that actually you know
not the before we're not styling this
yet just the button itself so save that
so we got the input checked the toggle
to button span tag so let's see what
happens over here in our browser click
it changes the background color the font
the font color the background and the
border color
perfect go back to your code editor one
last thing one last little bit of CSS
toggle - to input the checked state of
that input adjacent sibling selector
toggle to button now we're selecting
divorce before pseudo-element and we're
just gonna say background color is gonna
change to white now let's see what that
is that's that little circle that we
created go back to your browser click it
changes to white and then goes back to
gray wait gray so those are your buttons
there we go we did a lot of css3 there
we did the Facebook style buttons we did
the 3d buttons like that the gradient
border buttons the animated buttons with
the background moving and then that kind
of manipulating the padding and doing
some transitions we did the toggle
switches and this toggle switch here so
a nice little intro to css3 doing
something that's practical that you can
use in your websites right now so hope
you enjoyed day one I know that was a
lot to cover a hang tight for Game two
tomorrow I'll catch you there and we're
gonna be doing some really fun stuff
again so catch you later good day bye
[Music]